>>W PELE ARE GOING TER
YOACTING AS IF WE L KNOW
R CEAIN IT CAMEOUT OF A
LAB.
>> THE TRH IS WE'RE ILL
LOOKING THROUGA GLASS DARKLY
BECAE WEJU DON'T HAVE E
DATA.
>> YOU LOOK MYEMAILS I
NER IN E EMAI SAID
ANHING DEROGATO ABT
PRESIDT TRUMP.
THTRUE MA OF SOMEONE
TH LOOK GOODEVEN WHEN EIR
PEONAL EMAILS COME OUT.
YOU PASS THTEST>> Harris: DR. FH
NEY DID U GIVE OROW WAS
GIVEN TO THE WUHAINITUTE
AND KNOW TH WERE ING GAIN
OF FUNCTION?MANY INTHE MEDIA ST
OVERDR. UCI.
THE CORRESPONDCE KE IT
CLEATHATDR. FAUCS PRATE
BELIEFS HAVE BEENRADICALLY AT
ODDS TH HIS PUBL GUIDAN
AMERICAN PEOPLED E
WOE, THE EMAILSREAL A
REAUAT MORE INREST IN PROTECTI
THAN FINDINTHE TRUTH ABOU
THE CORONARUS.
STAFF MARKMEADOWPPED TH
DOCTOR'S EFRTS  SPIN WHAT
HESAID ISINTHOSE EMAILS.
>>THINTERESTING THINHERE
DR. FAUCI TRYING  CHANGETHE
LISTEN, THIS  NOT JUST ABOUT
WHATHAPPENED INA WUHAN LAB,
TH IS WH ACTUAL HAENED
WI DR. FAUCI INTHEARL
DA OF THE CORONAVIRUS
OUREAK
DRFAUCI HAS BEEN
FLIPLOPPING.
THERE IS MOREIP-FLOPS ON .
FAUCI THANYOU WILL ND ONA
NORTH ROLINA BEACH IN JULY
>>Harris: JOE CONCHA DIA ANPOLI.
JOE, EAT TO HAVE U ON THE
PROGRA
WE T INTOITWI MARC
THSSENWHO BROUT A GREAT
"WASHINGTOST" OPD ON THE
DEILS AND SEMANTS WH
NEEDS TO BE LOOK AT.
I WA TO KNOWWHERE IS THE
MEDION THIS?
IS  YO EXPEISE.WHAT'S PPENING WR
ANONY UCI SHOU BE ASKE
IN ANY INTEIEW.YOU TALKED ABT I
THSSENTHE LAST SEGMENT, IS
W CAN U SAY TH CHINIS
THIS AND  WE SAY NICE THIN
COOPERATIVE WI US NSIDERING
THE CHESE ANNOUNCED NOT TOO
NG AGTHAT THEY D CLOS
EIR INVESTIGION INTO
CORONARUS.
IT PPENED IN WEMARKET
THAT THE END OF IT AND EY
WON'T COOPERATIN ANY WAY,
SHAPE  FO.
W COD YOU SSIBLY DEND
THE CHINESE GIN THEITIONS
INCLING THIS INVEIGATION?
THAT'S A OD ESTION WE CAN
ART WITH.
OR U WEREMADE ARE BY OTR
IENTTS THAT THIS POSSIBLY
COULD BE LALEAKAS MUCHAS
A YEAR O AND YOU COINUED TO
DENYIT.
THAT INRESTING ASWELL.
OR HOW OUT ARGUG IN E
EML THAT REIL MASKS MAY NOT
BE VERY EFFECTE AGNST
CORONAVIRUON O OCCASIONS YOU SHD
DOMENTS THAT PERTAINE
IN OF NCTION RESEARCH.
NGEROUS RESEAR BUT INSTEAD
THESE ESTIONS AREN'TBEIN
ASKED AT ALL.
WE W THOSE TERVIEWS
YESTERY, RRIS, IT WAS KE
THE PRPINGUP OF A POLITICIAN
NAMED ANDREWUOMO
ITFELTVERY MUCH THE SAMEWAY.
>> HarrisI DOWA TO GO
DEEPER ON AT ASCT OF IT
BECAUSE IT MATTERAT THIS
DOCTOR SA BECAE SO MANY
PEOPLE LIEN TO HIM AND MANY
INTHE MEDILIFT HIUP.
OK, I KNOW YOU SATHE MONTAGE OF
RERTERS AND ANCHS COMING INTO U.
THEY'RFAWNG IN EPIC
PRORTIONS.
AT IS IN ITFOR THEMWITH
THAT>> I'NOT SU.
IT ISA BIG DISCONNE WITH THE
AMERICAN LL.
THE RASMUSSELL UND 2/OF
AMERICANS THK DR. UCI HA
BEEN OPERATG AND EING THIS
PANDIC THROUGH A POLITICAL
PRM.
T WHATTHE NAON'S TOP DOCTOR  SUN
I SAW ONCNN CORRPONDENT O
CRICIZ THIS NEORK FOR
QUE COVID ORIGINOCUS
CAN YOU IMAGINE IS.
THESARE THE MOST PORTANT
TOPI AND QUESTIS OF OUR
LIFETIME.
WHERDID THISVIRUS BEGI
HOW DID IT ORINAT
WHAT DID THE CHINESE KNOWAND
COVID 22, COVID .?SO WE CAN EVE
THAT'S THCRITICISM OF TH
NETWORIT'S TOO VID IGIN
FOCUSE
AT A ITICISM THE NETWORK SHOULDC
IFYOU HED THATARGUME
YOU'REDUMB FOR HAVING EN
IT.
>> rrisI HAVE HAD AN
AMICANGENERAL JACK KEANE SAY
EY HAVE MANY LA IN CHINA
ANDO WHAT WUHAIS DOING.
THEY'RE OKING AT GAIN OF FUNCTI
ANSPARENCY WITH THAT PROCS.
THEY CAN THK WHAT THEY NT
TO THINK ABT FOCUS BUT WE
HA QUESTION
I WANTTO GET  FACEBOOK
QUICKLY.
THEY LL NOUNCE AS SO AS
TOY THAT IT PLANS  D ITS CONTRO
MOSTLY SHIES POLICIANS FROM
THE NTENT MODETIONRULES THAT AP.
IT WOULD  A SHP REVEAL
AT ULD HA HUGE
OFFICIALS USE THE SOCI ED
NETWK.
YO REACTION.
AMING.
SOMEING LIKE 86% OF ERICS
T EIR NE ONLI.
LOT OF EM GET IT THROUG
TWTER AND CEBOOK.THEY ARPUBLHER
AT RY CLEAR.
E FUY THING IS EY SAI
READ  ONE STORY E CHGE
MES AFTER THOVERGHT
ARD,INDENDENT GROUP FUNDED
BY CEBOOK TO REVIEW ITS
THORNYEST NTENT RULINGS IT IS
NOT IS OVERSIGHT ARD
INPENDENT.
U WOULDN'T SEALL THE
RULIS AGNST CONSERVATIS
AND NER TOUCHING THE BLUE
TE.
AH, AT'S WHAT IS RULING
THNTENT WE SEE.THEY'RE CELE.
ERE IS  DUPROCS IN